o que a colaboração pode
ia fazer por nós
eu penso que a cidade é o nosso grande
território de criação na cidade ela me
parece tão intensa e tão imensa tão
diversa
eu tenho certeza que cada um de nós aqui
a gente tem um entendimento e uma
leitura diferente em relação à cidade
cada bairro cada território a cada rua e
parece que a gente deveria enxergar a
oportunidade de exercer a colaboração
para conseguir visualizar uma nova
perspectiva de apropriação em relação ao
território comum nas ruas
se a gente for perceber a abordagem dos
comuns ou do bem comum
quanto mais a gente usasse as ruas
melhor elas deveriam ficar muitas vezes
a gente não vê na prática isso acontecer
e afinal de contas quem se importa com a
cidade né
cada vez que eu faço essa pergunta essa
pergunta me parece atemporal
há nove anos atrás mais ou menos eu
iniciei as atividades do que hoje é a
nossa querida estúdio nômade junto com
meu sócio e irmão daniel caminho e eu
lembro que a gente trabalhou por
bastante tempo na sacada do apartamento
dos pais dele e à minha relação com a
cidade era outra eu ia e voltava a pé
por todos os dias para o trabalho ea
minha percepção do tempo e da dinâmica
da cidade era completamente outra em
relação ao que eu tenho hoje é durante
alguns meses eu pude observar uma obra
de escavação na esquina de um posto de
gasolina que aquilo foi me instigando
aquilo foi me provocando
eu não sabia muito bem o que estava
acontecendo naquela cratera que estava
sendo escavado
os dias foram passando e eu fui
descobrindo tanques enormes laranjas
tanque de gasolina pareciam bombas e
aquilo de uma maneira foi criando algo
em mim uma instigando eu não vou
esquecer um dia que eu cheguei na beira
da quebra cratera gigantesca e me dá
vontade de entrar lá dentro e fazer uma
performance
eu nunca tinha feito uma performance na
vida eu lembro que eu liguei para alguns
amigos
falei com eles vamos lá vamos fazer um
registro vamos entrar pra dentro e ver o
que acontece porque pode ser muito
interessante essa experiência não sabe
muito bem que quer que a dar
eu lembro que eu entrei lá pra dentro as
pessoas perplexas na volta não
entendendo nada
eu já circulava falava lá dentro daquele
buraco e e depois de um tempo esse gesto
de afetação em relação ao território a
gente foi descobrir a possibilidade de
criar um projeto foi o projeto
exorcismos urbanos
a gente fez uma série de performances ao
longo da cidade
a gente tem a possibilidade de criar uma
plataforma digital e convidar uma rede
de pessoas no mundo inteiro pra
compartilhar em lugares que estavam
abandonados e que pudessem por que não
criar uma nova rede de afetos em relação
ao território um processo muito parecido
é a gente conseguir viver constante
pública
esse projeto na época foram instaladas
prateleiras com livros nas antigas
paradas de ônibus da cidade e de alguma
maneira a gente teve uma grande
visibilidade em relação a esse projeto
saiu muita matéria na mídia em que era
convidado para falar em jornal para dar
entrevista em rádio e televisão
e a gente foi entendendo o sentido desse
projeto na medida que a gente ia falando
eu lembro que por mais que por algum em
alguns momentos a mídia divulgou que o
projeto não estava indo bem
de alguma forma os livros estavam
sumindo das prateleiras
mas o que menos a gente importava nesse
momento era os livros estavam lá não
estavam lá
a gente estava querendo entender a
dinâmica de colaboração no território
a gente se esquece muitas vezes o valor
do processo na dimensão do processo tem
uma história que esse projeto eu pouco
compartilhei e me sentir à vontade de
falar nesse fórum que o projeto ande
pública ele nunca teve autorização
formal para a gente conseguir fazer as
mais de 20 instalações em diferentes
pontos da cidade
o projeto sempre operou de maneira
ilegal e que a gente tentou fazer uma
aproximação em relação aos órgãos
competentes para conseguir essa
autorização
em determinado momento chega uma carta
com uma negativa dizendo que então o
projeto ele não estava autorizado porque
não existe um controle em relação ao
conteúdo que ser compartilhado nos
livros em próprio talvez para menores e
pra mim essa carta a gente tem guardada
até hoje ela é um símbolo da
incompreensão da dimensão da colaboração
eu entendo que a cidade é um território
de conflito que esses conflitos
eles se dão em diferentes níveis
diferentes camadas diferentes fóruns e
tem muito conhecimento tem muito saber
nessa troca na existência desse conflito
me parece que a gente se distancia de
mais na possibilidade de construir
diálogos colaborativo para conseguir
fazer desse conflito uma potência é hoje
as decisões dos rumos dos futuros da
cidade são tomadas em fóruns
privilegiados são tomadas em cima de
decisões muitas vezes não transparentes
decisões camufladas é um fórum argiloso
mas certamente não vim aqui para falar
de problemas certamente não vim aqui pra
trazer questões políticas que nos
impeçam de visualizar uma outra
criatividade em relação à cidade e me
parece que a gente precisa começar a
compreender o que significa afinal de
contas colaboração colaborar não é
apenas o ato de trabalhar em conjunto
colaborar
eu entendo o trabalho como a
possibilidade de criação colaborar mas a
gente colabora a gente está todo o tempo
compartilhando saberes saberes dos mais
diversos níveis dos mais diversos
valores
a gente precisa começar a valorizar os
diferentes tipos de saberes
a gente precisa encontrar lugar de
composição preços diferentes tipos de
saberes
quando a gente colabora a gente trocando
linguagem linguagem é uma das questões
mais complexas que a gente tem linguagem
está mudando a todo instante
nessa linguagem falada imagem corporal
linguagem gestual o que determina uma
linguagem para que a gente consiga
efetivamente colaborar
quem colabora vive processos intensos de
afecção colaborar é por um processo de
troca de afetos afeto no sentido de
carinho de cuidado de entender lugar de
fala de entender lugar de escuta de
compreender as brechas ea possibilidade
de composição
todas essas questões
elas envolvem a dimensão da colaboração
será que é tempo de a gente aprender
tudo isso com as urgências de problemas
que a gente tem na cidade
eu dedico boa parte do meu tempo hoje na
construção do primeiro laboratório
cidadão de porto alegre é o translado e
nesse espaço a gente desenvolve uma
série de articulações para conectar
pessoas e instituições para pensar em
soluções para os problemas complexos que
a cidade vive muitas vezes não sabe é
incompreendido
a gente precisa trabalhar cada vez mais
essa diminuição da linguagem para que a
gente consiga marcar uma diversidade de
pessoas muito além dos prêmios que o
translado já conquistou no brasil e até
mesmo fora do brasil
o translado é um lugar do exercício de
aprendizagem da colaboração
eu entendo que hoje a diversidade de
projetos que estão sendo elaborados
dentro desse contexto projetos ligados à
educação consumo consciente arquitetura
e urbanismo projetos ligados à moda
sustentável inovação social
todas essas questões elas contribuem
para que a gente consiga compreender
cada vez mais como a gente colabora
eu entendo que as soluções para os
problemas complexos não vão vir de
grandes organizações
as soluções para os problemas complexos
vamos vir da nossa capacidade de se
articular e de relacionar de uma outra
maneira a gente conseguir espaço de
criação
hoje entendo que cada vez mais a gente
tem uma relação asséptica com o
território territórios e de carinho se
aproximar
a gente precisa entender afinal de
contas o que nos afeta
no território quantos de nós
investem tempo de criação para conseguir
fazer coisas em relação ao processo de
transformação do território aos
problemas que nos afectam diariamente
quantos de nós
o translado e certamente não está
sozinho é hoje a gente reconhece uma
rede de casas colaborativas que da mesma
maneira como trunfo o abc vem
desenvolvendo dinâmicas de colaboração
cada uma do seu jeito
hoje já são mais de 10 casas
desenvolvendo dinâmicas colaborativas e
eu entendo que esses espaços
eles proporcionam dinâmicas de cura
o território ele tem um conhecimento
profundo
das necessidades do tipo território
precisa e conseguem certa maneira
articular novas dinâmicas de inovação e
de transformação social
para isso me parece que do ponto de
vista dos governos
o governo precisaria de muito mais
proximidade nesses espaços mas não a
proximidade para marcar presença na
próxima à proximidade criativa uma
proximidade que faça parte da agenda
política dinâmicas de criação com muito
menos exclusivistas hoje não se pensa
mas cidade favorecendo um território em
relação ao outro aprendizagem ela é
muito mais potente na complexidade do
território e muito menos priorizando
políticas de incentivo para territórios
específicos às empresas elas
proporcionam valor econômico mais
empresas se conectarem nas casas
colaborativas
eu entendo que hoje os modelos de
negócios mais inovadores que a gente
possa estar querendo visualizar então
sendo protótipo ados dentro das casas
colaborativas e são os novos centros de
inovação que as empresas poderiam estar
compondo as universidades
ela já entenderam o valor desse tipo de
espaço contribui para uma transformação
de futuro da cidade já são parceiras
próprio translado já recebeu diversos
trabalhos acadêmicos em todos os níveis
que a gente possa te querendo aqui
imaginar e eu faço parte dos sítios web
é um laboratório que eu me permito
produzir conhecimento em relação a essa
área também o cidadão cidadão principal
ator toda inovação ela está centrada no
cidadão tudo parte das necessidades dos
problemas reais que a gente vive
as casas precisam se preparar e
trabalhar cada vez melhor a abertura
para acolher o cidadão precisa processos
criativos
hoje as casas colaborativas elas
trabalham na facilitação entre governo
universidade
dão empresas trabalham nessa construção
desse diálogo criativo
penso que as casas colaborativas
elas precisam ter um cuidado para não se
institucionalizar em demais se tornarem
instituições formais
a gente vai perder a livre interação que
hoje se tem é que pra mim é um dos
principais ingredientes para desenvolver
novas dinâmicas de criação e de
apropriação em relação ao território e
por fim sempre uma escolha a gente
participar desses processos e se
permitir desenvolver uma nova dinâmica
de visão de mundo pra conseguir compor
junto com pessoas tão diferentes
parece que delegar para terceiros
a construção de soluções que afetam as
nossas vidas não só é uma postura omissa
mas principalmente o distanciamento de
sentir a transformação desse obrigado
[Aplausos]